Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich möchte mich kurz vorstellen. Ich heiße Seima Karakasli.
Ich bin auf dieser Sitzations als Assistenzärztin tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, wenig.
Kurz zum Ablauf werde ich zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten nach Abfragen dann Ihre aktuelle Bescheidung am Ende ein paar Informationen über Ihre Familie.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Manfred Holtkamp.
Manfred Holtkamp.
Und Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam stabilieren.
Manfred ist M-A-N-F-R-E-D.
Manfred.
Und der Nachname Holtkamp.
H-O-L-T-K-A-M-P.
M?
M.
M-P.
Holtkamp.
Herr Holtkamp.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 21. Oktober 1959.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 1,76 groß.
70?
Und wiegeln 90 Kilo.
Was tut Sie zu uns?
Ich habe einen Schmerz im Brustkorb und auch im Oberbauch.
Und unter dem Brustbein.
Also in der Mitte.
Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus, Herr Holtkamp?
Das war so grünlich, gelb und schleim. Aber das war auch nicht viel.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Brust zurückgefühlt haben und Oberbauch schmerzen.
Aber mehr in der Brust, mehr Brustdruck.
Und das geht so irgendwie in den Oberbauch rein.
Aber der Oberbauch, der Brustdruck, der ist schon ziemlich stark.
Aber Sie haben Brust schmerzen.
Könnten Sie genau beschreiben, sind diese Schmerzen dumpf, krampfartig oder brennende?
Also die haben ziemlich schnell begonnen.
Das ging ziemlich schnell.
Und die sind mehr so dumpf, drückend.
Also ob jemand so von außen einen Gürtel um den Brustkorb legt und zuzieht.
Sie sind so eng.
Also Gürtel für mich.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 kein Schmerz und 10 sehr starker Schmerz ist.
Ich würde sagen, im Anfang war das so 7.
Und dann habe ich meinen Nachbarn das gesagt und dann hat er mir so ein Spray gegeben.
Und dann hat er mir gesagt, den soll ich unter die Zunge sprühen.
Dann wird der Schmerz etwas besser.
Aber das war jetzt schon vor 2 Stunden.
Und jetzt werden die Schmerzen wieder schlimmer.
Okay.
Also hat dieses Spray bei Ihnen Verbesserung geholfen.
Ja, etwas hat etwas geholfen.
Kennen Sie der Name von der Spray?
Nein, das war so eine Packung.
Da stand irgendwas Rotes drauf.
Weiße Packung und rote Schrift.
Okay.
Wie sind diese Schmerzen auch aus?
Außer Gürtel vom Schmerz.
Eigentlich nur ein bisschen in den Oberbauch.
Unter dem Brustbein.
Ein bisschen links unter dem Brustbein.
Aber sonst strahlen die nicht aus.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Die sind ziemlich dauerhaft.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, das war bisher immer in Ordnung.
Ich muss in der Nacht einmal auf Toilette.
Aber das mache ich schon seit einigen Jahren.
Aber da hat sich nichts geändert.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen bemerkt?
Herzrasen?
Ne.
Ne, Herzrasen habe ich nicht beklopfen.
Das ist nicht so richtig.
Da müssen Sie öfter aufstoßen.
Manchmal nach dem Essen.
Wenn ich zu viel Mineralwasser getrunken habe mit Kohlensohre,
dann ist das manchmal so.
Aber sonst nicht.
Okay.
Sind diese Schmerzen nahelungsabhängig?
Also Brust- und Oberbauchschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Was sind diese Schmerzen?
Sind diese Schmerzen nahelungsabhängig?
Nein.
Das ging gestern los.
Heute Morgen los, da war ich beim Frühstück.
Aber ich hatte kaum etwas gegessen.
Ich habe Kaffee getrunken und dann begannen diese Schmerzen.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
diese Schmerzen lagierabhängig?
Ne, ich muss mich einfach ruhig verhalten.
Ich muss mich eigentlich auf die Luft hinsetzen.
Wenn ich etwas machen würde,
ich glaube, ich habe Angst, dass sie schlimmer werden.
Also, wenn Sie bewegen,
ist schlimm mein Sicht.
Ich habe die Befürchtung, ich habe Angst.
Ich habe es nicht ausprobiert.
Ich denke, lieber ruhig sitzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich würde Sie sich fieber.
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß oder Stilfrost?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe eigentlich in den letzten Jahren immer zugenommen.
Deswegen wiege ich jetzt 90 kg und da sagen alle meine Familie und mein Arzt,
sagt, das ist zu viel, ich muss Gewicht abnehmen, aber das ist schwer.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Innerhalb von einigen Jahren, wie viel Kilo haben Sie zugenommen?
Ich würde sagen, innerhalb der letzten fünf Jahre habe ich 10 kg zugenommen.
Leiden Sie unter Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein.
Was sind die Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchschlafen?
Nein, ich muss, wie gesagt, einmal in der Nacht muss ich raus zum Wasser lassen,
aber dann schlafe ich sofort wieder ein.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ja, der ist gut, ist zu gut, ich esse glaube ich zu viel.
Okay, Herr Colt, Leiden Sie ankronisch, Herr Kröngen?
Was meinen Sie unter chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine, Bluthochdruck, Blutzucker, Asthma oder...
Ich habe seit ungefähr 15 Jahren einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und dann nehme ich auch Medikamente für ein.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich habe das hier auf dem Zettel, da steht Furose mit.
10 steht dahinter, 1 morgens.
Okay.
Und Ramibriel, 5, 1 morgens und 1 halbe abends.
Und dann steht hier noch Misopolul, 5, 1 morgens und 1 abends.
Okay.
Und ja, fällt Ihnen noch etwas? Also nur Bluthochdruck?
Ja, sonst habe ich nicht so...
Allergie habe ich gegen Nickel.
Nickel?
Nickel, aber seitdem ich das weiß, ist das zwar so am Gürtel,
an dem Metall vom Gürtel, dass ich da dann ein,
hier so ein X-Sebengericht am Bauch,
aber seitdem ich das weiß, ist das nicht mehr so ein Problem für mich.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, mir wurde schon mal die Deilenblaser rausgenommen.
Vor ungefähr 6 Jahren hatte ich viele Steine
und vorher auch mal Gallenkoliken gehabt.
Okay.
Ist diese Operation komplikationlos per Lauf?
Alles gut.
Nehmen Sie außer diese Frosemith, Rangipril und Bisoprolol
irgendwelche Medikamente ein, also Schmerzmittel oder...
Ich nehme nichts ein. Bis auf dieses Spreeeben von dem Nachbarn.
Das nehme ich nichts ein.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich habe Corona, habe ich 3 Impfungen?
Krücht.
Angeblich soll ich jetzt bald die 4. Impfung kriegen,
aber warte ich mal noch ab jetzt, aber 3 habe ich.
Und sonst die normalen Impfungen gegen Tetanus und Differie und das habe ich.
Okay.
Ich habe vergessen zu fragen.
Also leiden Sie gerade an diese Schmerzen?
Also können Sie ertragen
oder soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben?
Also die sind jetzt schon ganz schön stark, die Schmerzen.
Also vielleicht, wenn Sie so einen Spreeeben, den ich da vom Nachbarn gekriegt habe,
aber ich weiß eben nicht, was das war,
aber der Nachbarn hat gesagt, es ist kein Astmaspreis.
Okay.
Lassen Sie uns über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe geraucht bis zu der Geilenoperation, also vor 7 oder 8 Jahren.
Und danach habe ich aufgehört.
Also seit 7 oder 8 Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie damals geraucht?
So 20.
Das war 55, 20, ja so gut 30 Jahre lang habe ich geraucht.
30, okay.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja früher habe ich mehr getrunken.
Früher habe ich so Bier regelmäßig abends 2 Flaschen getrunken.
Und jetzt trinke ich mal eine Flasche Bier, aber auch häufiger alkoholfreies Bier.
Okay.
Also ein Flasch Bier?
Ja, nicht mehr so regelmäßig.
Vielleicht jeden zweiten Abend trinke ich Bier mit Alkohol.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Hat es Ihre krönchen Erkrankungen, kennen Sie Herr Hothkamp?
Also mein Vater ist mit 74 Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Und die Mutter ist mit 70 Jahren an Blutkrebs, weißem Blutkrebs.
Ich glaube das heißt Leukämie gestorben.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder, er ist 2 Jahre älter als ich.
Er hatte voriges Jahr eine Operation am Herzalpass,
Freipass-Operation.
Wie ist Ihre Familienverstand?
Ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben keine Kinder, nein.
Was machen Sie von Berufrich?
Ich bin jetzt noch ein Jahr tätig, ich arbeite in der Verwaltung im Büro.
Eine sitzende Tätigkeit, ich bewege mich da nicht viel.
Okay.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt, haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie hinzufügen?
Mir fällt jetzt ein, dass so ich so in den letzten 4 Wochen,
wir wohnen im zweiten Stock ohne Fahrstuhl.
Und in den letzten 4 Wochen, wenn ich da die Treppen hochgestiegen bin
und vielleicht noch etwas übertragen habe, dann habe ich auch so diesen Druck gekriegt.
Aber nicht so stark wie heute.
Und dann, als ich dann oben war, dann ging das wieder weg.
Meine Frau hat gesagt, ich muss zum Arzt, ich muss dem Arzt das sagen.
Aber habe ich bisher nicht gemacht.
Also, wenn Sie hochsteigen möchten, bekommen Sie Atemnot?
Ja, das Druckgefühl, dieses enge Gefühl.
Okay.
Ja, fährt Ihnen noch etwas ein?
Ich bin immer neugierig, ich frage Sie, was kann das sein?
Okay, ja, nein.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt werde ich die Perfektion versuchen.
Dann Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Was sind Vitalparameter?
So Herzfrequenz oder Atemfrequenz, Sauerstoffsättigung
und natürlich EKG Scheiben.
Können Sie mir denn noch etwas von diesem Spray geben?
Bitte.
Dann geben Sie noch etwas von diesem Spray, der mir in meinen Nachbar gegeben hat.
Der hat ja etwas geholfen.
Ja, jetzt lege ich Ihnen einen Zugang ein.
Und dann bekommen Sie eine Schmerzmittel
und diese Schmerzen lindern sich.
Okay, gut.
So können wir es machen.
Danke.
Okay, und Sie schreiben jetzt fünf Minuten?
Okay, danke schön.
Gibt es Fragen vom Moderator?
Nein, aber wenn der Patent sagt, er habe ein Spray verwendet
und dieses Spray ist kein Asthma-Spray,
sollte uns direkt Nitro-Gelsen einfallen
und der Patent sollte sofort ein EKG machen,
gleichzeitig Vitalparameter überprüfen und Blut abnehmen.
Gut, ja.
Würde ich als Patient auch zustimmen?
Ja.
Okay, bis gleich.
Wir können das ja gleich noch besprechen.
Okay.
Okay, bis gleich.
Ja.
Gut.
Er zahlt mit, dass er seit vier Wochen Anginopektoris leidet
und berichtet, dass er Neusea und Vomitus leidet.
Seit heute Morgen oder seit schon länger?
Seit heute Morgen.
Ja.
Dass er brochen sieht grünlich und gelblich aus.
Okay.
Gut.
Hat er Riesbefaktoren?
Ja, er habe familiär Disposition.
In welcher Art?
Die familiäre Disposition?
Bei dem Vater, er sei an Neocardinfarkt verstorben
und seine Bruder wurde bei Pass-Operation durchgeführt.
Okay.
Er sei, ja, bitte.
Hat der Patient chronische Erkrankungen sonst noch?
Ja, er leidet an arteriellen Hypertonien.
Ja.
Und er ist übergewicht.
Hat er eine Raucher-Nikotin an am Nese?
Ja, ja.
Ja, okay.
Er rauchet 30 Jahre lang.
Ein Packung am Tag habe er geraucht.
Bis wann?
Hat er aufgehört?
Vor sieben, acht Jahren habe er damit aufgehört.
Ja, warum hat er da aufgehört?
Also für die Operation, also Kohlestectomie.
Ach so, da war eine Kohlestectomie.
Und gut, danach hat er aufgehört.
Ja, okay.
Ja, also ein vegetative Anamnese.
Er habe innerhalb von fünf Jahren 10 kg zugenommen.
Ja.
Und er leide unter Nocturil, einmal pro Nacht.
Aber das war nicht anders als sonst.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ja, laut der anamnestischen Angaben gehe ich von Myokartinfarkt aus.
Differenzial diagnostisch kommen Angina pectoris.
Diese Schmerzen sind guter für mich.
Vielleicht kann das auch pancreatitis sein.
Hat der Patient eine Magen an einem Nese?
Ja, er hat einmal erbrochen.
Und sonst früher hatte er früher mal Ulcus ventricoli, Ulcus duodini.
Ja, er hat nicht erwähnt.
Okay, okay.
Ja, also ich denke mir, so wie Sie das schildern, muss man an eine zumindest klarer Karten denken,
Angina pectoris gegebenenfalls sogar Myokartinfarkt.
Und da ist jetzt ja auch Eile geboten.
Da müssen wir jetzt zügig handeln.
Wenn der Patient berichtet, hat er wirklich Nito-Spray genommen,
wissen wir das oder ist das Ihre Vermutung?
Ja, anamnestisch nur ein Spray.
Hat er den Spray genommen, hat er ihn eingeatmet oder hat er ihn in den Mund gesprüht?
Ja, in den Mund gesprüht.
Okay, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass das wahrscheinlich ein Nitro-Spray war.
Und dieser Spray hat ihm ja wohl etwas geholfen?
Ja, genau.
Das sollte auch uns schon etwas darauf hin.
Also wichtig ist, denke ich, wenn so ein Patient kommt, sollte man nicht groß jetzt die vegetative Anamnese erheben,
sondern die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Während Sie den Patienten fragen, können Sie den Blutort messen?
Können Sie STU-Spray messen?
Können Ihnen eventuell an einen Monitor hängen?
Das ist etwas, was, glaube ich, den Patienten auch sehr beruhigt.
Weil der hat ja Schmerzen, dem ist ja nicht gut.
Und der kommt ja nicht aus Langeweile zu Ihnen, sondern er sagt, ich brauche Hilfe.
Und da macht es Sinn, wenn das Richtung Herz geht, nicht die Anamnese so dem, sondern sagen,
Herr Holzkamp, ich messe jetzt erst gerade Ihren Blutdruck, ich messe Ihren Sauerstoff-Gehalt im Blut
und hängen Sie an einem Monitor an, dann kann ich sehen, wie Ihr Herz schlägt.
Und ich gebe Ihnen jetzt testweise nochmal einen Spray.
Weil er gesagt hat, klein der Schilderung, die Wirkung des Sprays hat nachgelassen.
Das war anfangs gut, aber jetzt hat er wieder mehr Schmerzen.
Wichtig ist einfach bei solchen Patienten, dass man akut während der Anamnese etwas tut,
was in die Richtung, glaube ich, geht, sie machen nichts falsch damit
und der Patient ist schon mal beruhigt, weil es wird etwas getan, es wird gehandelt.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz wichtig.
Und da würde ich einfach, sollte sie in der Prüfung so einen Patienten bekommen,
dann würde ich in aller Ruhe sagen, Herr Holzkamp, hier haben wir den Monitor, ich messe den Blutdruck
und das und dann bin ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen und dann sind wir auf der sicheren Seite erstmal,
der Diagnostik schon mal.
Und ich glaube, das macht auch einen guten Eindruck vor den Prüfern.
Wenn es Richtung Kerz geht, wenn der Patient jetzt ein dickes Knie hat
und sagt mir, tut das Knie so weh, und das ist so dick,
da müssen Sie jetzt nicht, SPO zwei messen und den Blutdruck sofort und hast ein Monitor,
sondern da können wir erstmal in aller Ruhe Anamnese erheben und, und, und.
Sie haben sehr gut, finde ich, und sehr ruhig die Anamnese erhoben.
Sie haben auch dann die Patientensprache übersetzt in die Fachsprache.
Das haben Sie gut gemacht und denken Sie nur dran, wenn der Patient sagt, Sie haben gefragt,
seit wann haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Dann sagt der Patient, seit drei Stunden.
Dann ist eigentlich die nächste Frage einmal der Charakter des Schmerzes,
aber dann ist die nächste wichtige Frage, hatten Sie so einen Schmerz schon mal?
Ja, ist es das erste Mal, dass Sie diesen Schmerz hatten?
Oder ist das schon häufiger passiert?
Und dann sagt er, in den letzten vier Wochen merke ich beim Treppensteigen,
dann geht der Brustgob so zu.
Und da sollte man ja schon etwas hellhörig werden.
Dass das doch eine, eine, eine sicherlich anginapectoris ist,
die in Richtung vielleicht dann doch eines Gefäßverschlusses schnell geben kann.
Ja.
Ja, aber sonst finde ich, wenn Sie weiterhin dabei schön ruhig bleiben,
den Patienten anschauen und Ihre Struktur, Ihre strukturierte Anamnese machen,
dann finde ich das gut.
Danke schön.
Wie lange haben Sie noch Zeit zur Prüfung?
Also mein Termin ist 21. Mai.
Okay. Und ich frage immer, wo?
Gestern.
Wo?
Hessen.
Okay.
Ja, aus meiner Sicht, Sie hatten das ja auch angemerkt mit dem Nitrospray.
Wenn es kein Astmaspray ist, das habe ich so extra gesagt.
Also der Nachbar hat gesagt, das ist kein Astmaspray.
Dann kommt eigentlich nur noch ein Nitrospray, glaube ich, in Betracht.
Gut.
Ja, gibt es noch irgendwelche Anmerkungen oder Fragen?
Haben wir etwas vergessen?